In 1838 the German educator Friedrich Fröbel
laid the foundations of modern education when
he opened the "Play and Activity Institute".
Fröbel soon called his institute a Kindergarten
, reflecting his belief that young children
should be nurtured and nourished "like plants
in a garden”.
Fröbel, who studied under the Swiss educator
Johann Pestalozzi, established the idea that
games and playing are typical and essential
forms of life.
Activities in the kindergarten included singing,
dancing, gardening, and self-directed play.
Quality time spent like this was a considerable
improvement to the life of many children,
given that the alternative was often to help
parents with work.
He also introduced the concept of "Frei-Arbeit",
which can be translated into "free work".
During set periods of time, children were
allowed to work on things by themselves.
Where many adults saw pointless play, Fröbel
saw important learning taking place . While
practicing their concentration skills and
resilience,the children also learned about
engineering, logic and physics.
To help facilitate this process, he developed
a set of educational toys known as Fröbel
Gifts . The set contained 20 objects, such
as balls, blocks, and sticks.
Fröbel carefully designed the toys to help
the children in his kindergarten recognize
and appreciate common patterns and forms found
in nature.
His innovative ideas soon found appeal and
many young educators came to learn from Fröbel
and to see the immense potential displayed
by children at his institute.
Later, many of Fröbel’s students opened
their own Kindergarten and Germany experienced
a rapid growth in the numbers of early childhood
centers.
Then something bad happened.
After suppressing the German revolutions of
1848–49, the Prussian government started
a crackdown on new democratic ideas and women
were forbidden from being politically active.
The fact that some were operating a kindergarten
all by themselves was seen as problematic.
And so it didn’t take long for the government
to label Fröbel’s Kindergarten ideas as
dangerous to both the State and church; soon
all schools that followed Fröbel’s principles
were banned.
For Fröbel, who saw his life’s work destroyed
and the future of all the children disrupted,
this was a terrible blow.
He died in dismay just a year later.
But the ban caused a diaspora of kindergarteners
who could no longer work in Germany, spreading
Fröbel’s ideas all over the world.
One of Fröbel's students founded the first
kindergarten in the United States in 1856.
But the story was far from being over.
Exactly 20 years later, a young woman named
Anna Lloyd Jones stumbled upon a set of Fröbel’s
Gifts at a visit to the first World's Fair
in the United States.
Anna, a teacher by training, was so excited
by the wooden toys that she bought a set for
her nine-year-old son.
Little Frank loved the toys his mother brought
home and began building all kinds of geometrical
structures — first with the wooden toys,
later in miniatures and with other materials.
Without formal training, Frank Lloyd Wright
became one of the world’s most renowned
architects, responsible for some of the most
iconic buildings in modern architecture, many
of which resemble Fröbel's toy blocks.
Germany lifted its ban on kindergartens in
1860, realizing that it was a terrible mistake.
And while Fröbel wasn’t around anymore
to witness the rebirth of his ideas in his
homeland, they continued to spread around
the world and became an inspiration for Maria
Montessori, Rudolf Steiner, and many others
who set out to innovate formal education.
Fröbel once said that “Play is the highest
expression of human development in childhood,
for it alone is the free expression of what
is in a child's soul.”
Frank Lloyd Wright described the influence
of such play in his approach to design as
follows: "For several years, I sat at the
little kindergarten table-top… and played…
with the cube, the sphere and the triangle—these
smooth wooden maple blocks…
All are in my fingers to this day.”
How was your personal experience with play
and learning when you were young?
Did you go to kindergarten?
And what are your thoughts on the play as
a way of growth and development?
Share your thoughts!
To download this video without background
music, or learn more about the topic, visit
sproutsschools.com